national pride hasn't just been visible
on the track in Doha fans from more than
80 countries have made the Khalifa
Stadium their home for the Middle East's
First World Athletics Championships so
we are here to support them everywhere
they go they take the flag hi I love you
too watching it alive for sure it's live
and you feel it yeah I watch me as well
do you know you cannot feel you can not
feel the crowd on the phone it has to be
in a stadium sports really gather every
single nation like you know I felt like
we're just all humans like we don't even
know about nations anymore global events
bring with them global scrutiny the
presidents of world athletics Sebastian
Coe said he would have preferred to have
seen more people in the stadium for
certain sessions he believes taking his
Sports biggest standalone event to new
countries beyond its traditional borders
is vital to track and field's future we
live in a global society there is no
organization no structure no institution
out there that isn't trying to figure
out how we embrace more of that not pull
up the drawbridge and decide that this
really isn't for us the feedback from
athletes about their in-stadium
experience has been generally positive
air cooling technology ensuring
temperatures in the main arena wear a
pleasant 25 degrees Celsius the venue is
world-class it was amazing the best
conditions we've had all your awesome
runway awesome pit I think we should go
into places where it may not be as
prevalent and introduce the sports of
people that may not watch it because if
you do go to attract men and you watch
it you're going to love it
cats are will next step into the global
sporting spotlight in December when it
hosts football's Club World Cup Andy
Richardson al Jazeera Doha